If because there was moose, goose, loose, noose. I mentioned this on my other podcast, Arraycast. Check it out every two weeks on Saturday. What is this? No, no, absolutely not. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 65, recorded on February 5th, 2022. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we mention the CPP North call for papers deadline, which is on February 21st, the positions that NVIDIA is currently hiring for, and then
Bryce gives me a custom Wordle to solve live. It's the return of hat Connor, of baseball cap connor what's up what's good reverse baseball cap connor i can't see your hair buddy where's your hair i gotta see those locks god we haven't talked in like a while because well not uh yeah not not one-on-one i mean january 15th was the last time we recorded it is Really? Wow, that feels like Yeah, I mean, it's February 5th We can announce What are we doing here?
We can announce a couple things How are we doing this? Well, first we're playing Wordle Because I can't Wait, let me I just gotta type down a couple things So I don't forget to bring them up in the next episode. Oh, I got an appointment for an important...
Let me try that sentence again. I got an important first announcement, which is that I am hiring C++ compiler engineers. So if you want to come and work at NVIDIA on exciting new C++ compilers, send me a DM or an email or a smoke signal or a letter or find me on the streets of Manhattan. Any of those options work. Any of those options work. Are we going to post a N you know, NVIDIA portal, like, job description? No?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Because you have to email me and then I refer you. And then I refer you. That may be because that is the way that Bryce gets the referral bonus. But also that's the way that I make sure that the HR team actually brings you in for an interview interview like i looked your resume and like i'm like oh yeah this person's good and then i'm like hey bring in this person for an interview yep juicy content um you're figuring out why bryce really does it let's be honest someone may well of the two of us one of us may have gotten a hiring bonus for bringing the other person into our current company.
I still owe you like a fancy dinner. Don't wait. Don't you owe me a fancy dinner from that? I don't want to talk about that. I don't want to talk about that. I owe you like a very, I owe you at least one very fancy dinner and one somewhat fancy dinner from the bet about the Prague committeeg uh uh committee meeting video which i was hoping that like the pandemic would make you forget that i i had promised to take you to like
that i had lost a bet that involved me taking you to a 300 a person sushi restaurant but that sushi restaurant was in in california like where neither of us live there still. Oh, yeah. So if I can get reservations, which I'm almost certain I can't, I'll take you to Eleven Madison Park instead, which is a three Michelin star restaurant in New York that apparently has recently switched to like an all vegetarian menu or maybe it's all vegan.
It's fine with me. And the reviews are like not great um but i'm like not famous enough to to get reservations there but i'll try for you for you i appreciate that whenever i make it down to uh new york so that's uh so nvidia's hiring and i guess uh i was gonna say i'll announce that cpp north call for papers is open however yeah i submitted my time by the time that this or i should have been in my keynotes right because you're gonna make me a keynote right it's uh no but but who are the keynotes i hear we have some pretty exciting keynotes for we do we have two of our keynotes announced uh sean parent and kate gregory two of like the best speakers in c++ yeah uh it's
pretty exciting pretty exciting unfortunately though by the time this airs i mean our first wordle episode that we recorded i believe on the 15th which is the last time we recorded just was out yesterday on february 4th yeah yeah and so by the time this one goes out it's going to be like tail end of February and Call for Papers is actually closed. So thanks to the podcast editing gods. This episode is actually coming out on February 18th, three days before the Call for Papers for CPP North
closes on February 21st at 1159 p.m. Eastern Standard Time Zone. So if you have been on the fence about submitting, this conference is going to be in person. We are aiming to design a super inclusive conference that highlights not just experienced speakers that you've seen at other conferences before, but new speakers that you've never seen before. So if you have been hesitant about submitting to other conferences in the past, this is definitely the time to submit now. Back to the episode. Wait, really? We have that much back like so we didn't mean to record
this week because you had enough stuff for next oh yeah we've got at least one maybe two episodes on the backlog but it's all right because we haven't caught up and we definitely uh this is the thing so the last time we recorded i had only played Wordle eight times. And I would say that my strategy was unsophisticated. Yeah, I think our strategy is still... So, listener, you have to understand that Wordle has taken over our life. I now spend 20 to 30 minutes a day playing the Wordle. And then Connor and I have a debrief, which is, like, I don't know, probably a good 30 minutes to an hour of back and forth of
us talking about Wordle strategy. It's just become a part of our, like every day, every day. And then, and then my new thing is that we're going to start just playing Wordle like amongst ourselves. Like I have a word today. It's going to be really rough for Connor. We're going to, we're going to have him play it live and we're going to see if he gets it. So here's the thing. Someone pointed out recently that I say that a lot. Here's the thing. And so now anytime I say that, I catch myself saying it. The New York Times, so update about Wordle.
The New York Times has purchased Wordle. I mentioned this on my other podcast, Arraycast. Check it out every two weeks on Saturday. What is this? No, no, absolutely not. Is Bryce jealous? Yes. Is Bryce a jealous podcast co-host? So the point being is that our streaks, everything, let's be honest, the New York Times is going to, they're going to mess that up. They're going to mess that up. I was going use a more a stronger like two days ago messed up my streak anyway so whatever but the point is is wordle's going away so for those of you for the listener for you thinking i came here
for juicy algorithm data structure content uh don't worry these wordle episodes they're ephemeral they're only here for a limited time only special no because because wordle you don't need the website to play Wordle. You just need a friend. That's true. But the exciting part is actually doing it live. Anyways, we had unsophisticated. So back then, our starting word was tears.
Since then, our starting word, or at least my starting word, has been a rose. Yeah, and I've used that too. But I apparently, I've learned recently that that is not actually the optimal word. Some people on TikTok had figured out like the best first word based not only on letter frequency, but also on if that word is a miss, how many like options does it eliminate? And so I heard that like irate is a really good one. And there's a few others that are like better than that. But I hear that arose is not the best one.
Although we have had good success with it. Except for like two days ago when I got just absolutely wrecked. And don't want to talk about it. I'm still emotional. Yeah, it's understandable. That was a tricky one. The word Bryce is referring to is shard. And honestly honestly there's
been a couple words now where i've been real concerned even what was it pleat the other day oh pleat was tough these words were the worst situation because i've realized that this was never intentional but i've always played in hard code hardcore mode which is where you always use your information so like in our last Wordle episode, we talked about going from tears to found or hound. That is not hard code, hardcore mode, because you're not using the A that you know is in the word. So hardcore is where you always use that information. So some people, they just choose three random words that don't overlap, like arose until, and then some third word. So
then you get like a really good, you know, set of, if not all five, but you know, four out of five of your words, and you can probably make a decent guess. But that is not hardcore mode. Well, no, I think that's harder than our way of playing. I think it depends on the word. Sometimes it'll make it incredibly easy if you know all five letters and, you know, one of them, the right position and the other, the four. I like how there's like, there's now there's like schools of thought for how to play Wordle. Yeah. But the trickiest situation, in my opinion, is where you get down to four green letters. Yeah.
And you have one missing one. And there are multiple options because you're hooped then. For the day that I, for the day that we had Pleat, I had all four letter – I had all five letters just out of place. So I think that like – and I guess – I think I guessed like plate before pleat. Yeah. Yeah. I can tell based on your letters. It was like either petal or plate or something like that.
No, maybe it was petal. I think it was petal. I think it was petal. Yeah. So my second guess just luckily was petal. And I've also realized that – so on the day that it was Pleat, we guessed a rose that had A and E. And I've realized that like rarely do words end in S as like plural nouns or do they end in ED as in a past tense verb. So a lot of the times I would typically guess in the past like caned, C-A-N-E-D.
Rarely ever does the word end in E-D. So now I've started to try and go for more like atypical words like metal, which ended up turning out really well. But in the case of metal, I knew that it ended up, because my third guess was cleat, but then you end up with pleat and bleat as your two other options. And luckily, I had gotten to the point where I had more guesses than I had possible words left. But there were certain days like when I ended up guessing moose as my third guess, and you'd called me so Canadian. Yes. And what that was those. In that case, I had OSE at the end. And I wasn't sure if because there was moose, goose, loose, noose. I think loose I had already rolled out because I'd used an l but the point
being is that i got really worried that day because if it was going to be a double o word i didn't i didn't i don't think i had enough guesses to go through all of moose goose noose and at that point like it's just luck of the draw and like the one that like scares me well no i'm not going to tell you the one that scares me because at some point i'm going to make you play for the one that scares me part of uh point I'm going to make you play for the one that scares me. Part of this ongoing every three or four episodes now, the way I edit it, we'll do Wordle, is I will introduce a couple valid Wordle words that probably people don't know. Because if we want to keep this streak alive, however long this lasts, we need to start to learn these words. So in the last episode, when we were trying to come up with words that were like in the pattern of basin or nadir that were A, I in the second and fourth position or in those reversed that didn't have T, R, S or E in them, there ended up being eight.
There was 49 of them, I think, because we looked up and using all the letters T, R and S, there was like 127. I looked it up. There was 49, but only eight of them were valid word or words. And let's see if I can remember them off the top of my head. So the one that we guessed, cabin, was one of them. And then there was magic, panic, manic, which actually I was very confident that I knew the word. It could have been manic. I should not have been as confident as I was. I was like, oh, I know it.
That was my hubris and arrogance there. It could have just as easily been manic and not panic. So yeah, cabin, manic, panic, magic, vapid. Vapid's a good one. There was two other that I'm going to forget. But one of them was cavil, I believe, which was C-A-V-I-L, which I looked up and meant to carp, which I know carp is a fish. I did not know that was a verb. And that, I mean, the listeners already heard this. I'm just repeating this. I was surprised that Paris is on the word list. I used that the other day and didn't even expect it to hit.
Yeah. Okay. All right. All right. So I'm going to have you play. So wait, can we do the actual real world first? No, no, no, no, no. I'm too, I'm too excited about the one that I have for you. All right. We're doing two back to back wordles here. This one's a fake one though. So, so earlier this week I had Connor play a word. I just picked a word and I'm like,
start guessing. And I told him it was a proper noun and he got it in like two shots because of course I picked my name. It was like, you know, my vanity just really tripped me there. So your word today, Connor, it is not a wordle word. It's not on the list, but I will tell you this, it's a brand. So give me your first guess. And I'm going to send you, I have myself all set up here to send you the little Unicode results for each one of your guesses on Twitter. So it's a brand. All right. My first guess is a rose. Well, I guess this is a podcast, so I'll have to verbally describe it anyways. So Connor Guesta rose, and he got a hit on the O, but not in the correct place.
And everything else was a miss. Interesting. I was going to have a potentially N2, and I got excited when you said O in the wrong place. Because I also have a brand that is five letters that I would already choose for you. I can tell you it now. It's Exxon. E-X-X-O-N. That's freedom. But you didn't say E, so it's clearly not Exxon.
So all right. So it's just the O, correct? Yeah. Just the O. That's all. Okay. So here's the thing. I'm trying to think, should I actually try and start guessing brands? So like Just the L. That's all. Okay. So here's the thing. I'm trying to think,
should I actually try and start guessing brands? It's like, like do hardcore mode, but also start guessing brands. I mean, I'm getting, I am being generous in that my, I am not giving you a word list of solely brands, which I feel like would be very challenging. I'm letting you use the regular word list, but I'm just telling you that the word that it's going to be is a brand. So I guess if you don't like unless if that one, the word ends up being one of those words, you're taking off the opportunity. So Mark Harris ended up getting a moist in two. I also got moist in two, but he already tweeted about it.
I got, I got, I got it in one because I figured out just from what he had. That's cheating. I mean, it was the equivalent as if I got it in two because he got, I knew what, what I knew that he played our starting word,
and so I knew what he got for the first one. But I feel like you and I have a pretty good rate of getting it in two or three. No, no. So I've only ever gotten it in two once, and that was moist. But I feel like we have a pretty good rate of getting it in three. But anyways, but anyways. Getting it in two, though, the difference emotionally, how that feels oh yeah yeah yeah it is i think i've maybe i've gotten it in two more than you but i've definitely gotten i definitely had more varied performance than you yeah i i saw someone that that had a total miss on their i showed you that that the one that you
got it in three someone had a total miss and then their next guess total green yeah that was light i think that was the one that was on light anyways should we go for i mean if o is not in the middle it's either going to be a word like founder hound or should we go for something that has like a tch because we don't actually have... Oh, actually, wait. Isn't there a... Oh, no. I was going to think of that
automotive company Bosch, B-O-S-C-H. Would have been a good guess, but we don't have an S. It would have been a good guess. Let's just go with... We're going to go with the guess of the word notch. N-O-T-C-H. Well, I've got good news for you and bad news for you
the good news is that there is an o in the second letter the bad news is everything else is a miss okay so you've got an o in the second place. I was going to say there was a brand, Pocky, right? That Japanese sort of wafer. And that's like P-O-C-K-Y, I think. But there's no C in it now. That sucks. Never going to get it. He's never going to get it.
Do I know this brand? Oh, yeah. You know this brand. Okay. I'll get it then. What are we talking about? So clearly Bryce has gone for atypical letters. So that's what we got to switch our strategy to here at this point.
The question is, is it four consonants or is there an I and a Y? I say we just try. So is there a way to get an I and a Y guessed at the same time? Let's do it. You know, it would be really evil if the brand is O is UFOs. O-O-F-O-S. But there's no S. So it can't be UFOs. And I'm actually wearing UFOs right now. UFOs are running recovery sandals. Yeah, I know. I have I have a pair of those. Yeah, they're wonderful. Yeah, I got them. I got them the week that I moved to New York. I got a pair of those recovery
shoes. Oh, we haven't guessed an L. So oily. What are the words that coily? No, we already guessed C. Doily. That's a word, right? D-O-I-L-Y. Actually, let's just... I'll check the word list. No, no. Doily's on the list. All right. Let's go with doily. Let's see how far we get. So there is an L hour but not in that place oh that's that's very useful here's a problem and i'm not sure if i should be maybe you can well you don't have uh you don't have my program though yeah are you using your program no no i'm not that's because it's i'm just i i have it set up to be able to use it
but i think the problem with using proper nouns i'm sure there is at least one word or a couple words but like i'm not actually sure there are many valid words left that i can guess like in in the dictionary yeah you may be no i'm sure that there's still i'm sure that like given that set of words that you have i I'm sure that you have options. I'm not sure. Like, cause I haven't guessed U yet. So I'm almost positive. The problem is, is that I have guessed both N and D.
So I think all of the O U words are all gone, which means that it's probably a word that is like O blank U. And when you put the L in there as well. So actually, yeah, go to wineverygame.com and type in question mark O. Is this the thing that I should be using for Wordle? No, it's just an anagram solver. You want me to type in? Question mark O, question mark U, question mark oh question mark you question mark and then
type that in again for the prefix and then also filter like visually filter by ones that have an l in it and my guess is that it's like you've got yeah you don't have many options how many do i have um i think none that don't reuse some letters that you know aren't there none no no there are words but they just words that use letters that you know aren't in it yeah i mean that's so that's the problem is that is there actually a valid word i'm trying to think um yeah there's plenty of valid words you might might just have to know, but like an actual valid word that doesn't reuse. That's the thing is probably not. Maybe there's two O's.
Maybe I'm getting way too, um, maybe there's two O's. It could be that, right? Or there could be a U. I just, I love the one that for once there's a quiz on this show where, um, I'm not the one that's suffering where Connor's the one that's suffering where connor's the one that's suffering oh mogul m-o-g-u-l is that a valid word that's i'm gonna i'm gonna let you play it is it is it check it just isn't your is it on your win every game list um i know that mogul is definitely a word so there is that is that's a valid word that doesn't
use any repeats you have the same thing as before uh there's no there's no u um the l is still out of place i just thought of rolex but that's definitely not valid you had you had you had a good idea before i'll tell you that you had a good idea before you didn't pursue it but you had a good idea before two l's hey or two o's xerox is also not gonna be it xerox is an interesting one i should xerox is actually xerox is actually a valid um scrabble word i'm not sure if it's in the probably it's not in the wordle dictionary but um um i'll check if it is that's gonna be a miserable day oh my god it is there that's going to be a miserable day. Oh, my God, it is. There's also like I can't remember if it's a dating app called Zoosk.
Z-O-O-S-K, I think. And I'm at four guesses. So basically I can get one more info guess. Yeah. So let's go. We're going to go for two O's. Yeah. Ideally like an L in the middle because I don't have like a Y or something to put at the end
it's unlikely it's going to be L-O-O consonant consonant so you know that the L can't be in the last it's either the first or the third so yeah my options are like L-O-O something something or O-L-O in the middle
but then I don't actually think that there's a word. Search me that on your win every game. Is there a question mark, O-L-O question mark? Question mark, O-L-O question mark. And like obviously color. And there's a couple others, I'm sure. Colon, you know, et cetera. But like is there one that uses just Q-W-P- K, F, Z, X, V, G, and J?
Not even close. So like, I don't even know how to go about guessing. So it's like in order to guess a word, I'm not actually going to be able, I'm only going to be able to get one extra consonant. So I'm going to have to choose one. So like I could guess Polka, P-O-L-K-A, that gets me the O, the L, not the second O, and also reuses an A. So really what I should do is try and just find any brand at this point, because other brands should be guessable. Yeah, I'll let you guess. I'll let you guess any brand. How about any seemable word?
Can I make a word up? Like, you know, Polob, P-O-L-O-B or something like that. P-O-L-O-B. That's not my actual guess. Not my actual guess, for the record. And you'd have to even let me know if something like that would be allowed. So what should I be going for? I feel like I should definitely go for the second O.
I should just try and get O-L-O. I'm going to heavily edit this down. I know you are. This is going to take some time. I mean, I'm looking at like the O-L-O words and see if there are any that give you like one. You know, you could do, there's a word here, polis, which would reuse an S,
but you know, what's your guess? Oh, polos? Like P-O-L-O-S. Yeah, polos. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. That's not bad. Although the cynic in me is like the only reason Bryce is throwing you that bone
is because it doesn't help you at all. Other than the fact that I know the cynic in me is like the only reason Bryce is throwing you that bone is because it doesn't help you at all. Other than the fact that I know that it'll give, it'll give me, it'll lock in that the L is in the first or third and whether there's another O, you know what? Let's do it.
Let's do it. Polos. Polos is a valid word. I have, I have good news for you, which is that the L is in the right place. And there's no P. And no second O?
There's not a second O in the place that you guessed it. But if it's an O in the wrong place, that should be yellow. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. I'm sorry. You're correct. Wow. Look at that. Bryce at the finish line almost tripped and lost the game because he doesn't know how to give me the correct information. You're right.
You're right. It's green, green, yellow. Yeah, green, green, yellow. Yeah. So he did actually message me the wrong thing. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's true. All right.
So at this point, we actually should be able to guess it. We know it's blank O-L. So let's see. Blank, blank. So you know that the O is either in the first or the last. So you know you've got, you know. And so that's actually interesting are there any brands that start with ool uh the only one that comes to mind which is not ool it's ook is ooklas the uh
speed um the speed test for your browser that most people use and remember this is this is a well known brand like yeah so that wouldn't be it you will know it and yeah ool is pretty unique that i'd have to like i'd have it'd be have to be a pretty big swing and a miss i apologize listener if you're screaming at your earbuds right now being like come on how can he not know the ool brand so we will give up on that so then if you've got ol andL and then if you've got question mark, O-L, question mark, O, what could it possibly be? Oh, I know. I just typed out underscore O-L underscore O. And in my head, I was thinking polio.
But then as soon as I realized, oh, right, we have no more vowels. Connor is going to lock it in on the six guests with Volvo. You got it. Nice work. Nice work. I'm so proud of you. That was totally worth the substantial amount of editing you're going to have to do. Yep.
Not a bad one. I still actually think Exxon's a bit worse. I do think Exxon's worse. Yeah, but don't worry. I got worse ones coming for you. All right. Are we doing the actual Wordle now? All right. We're going to do the real Wordle now. Are you going to screen share? I wasn't even joking when I said this podcast is just about Wordle now. All right, all right.
You know what the tricky part is, though? Oh, actually, so let's do a quick analysis. Let me, because I was typing it in, but I haven't run my Wordle program. So it was a Rose Notch, Doily Mogul, and Polos. Yeah. Let's see how many actual words. So yeah, so after the the third guest doily
there were only two words that i could have guessed um the first one was woeful w-o-f-u-l and that's not a valid wordle word and then the other one is mogul so i got i guessed one of the two words after i guess mogul there are no, my program shows that there's zero words left in the Wordle dictionary. So that's the hard part about doing brands is that I'm then forced to start reusing letters. But yeah, you helped out with polos. That is a polis. That's worse than wagon or whatever I said. Thanks for listening.
We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.